[MUSIC PLAYING]
POLONG LIN: In this
video, I'll show you
how to build and
deploy a recommendation
system with BigQuery ML.
My name is Polong Lin and
I'm a developer advocate
for Google Cloud.
From finding the right
Halloween costume,
getting notified
of relevant spooky
decorations for your home,
the majority of consumers
today expect personalization,
recommendations
of products and
services, or content
tailored to their interests.
And so, in order to better
serve the customers,
businesses need to be able to
train and deploy recommendation
systems quickly and effectively
to improve conversions,
click-through rates, and build
customer satisfaction, loyalty,
and brand affinity.
But to build
recommendation systems,
you need a place for your data.
Google BigQuery is a fully
managed, highly scalable data
warehouse solution
on Google Cloud.
It comes with lots
of great features,
especially around
storage and analytics.
Without needing to move
your data out of BigQuery,
with BigQuery ML, you can
train and deploy machine
learning models
directly using SQL.
That means you've got data
storage, analytics, and machine
learning all within BigQuery.
So how can businesses create
recommendation systems quickly
and deploy them into
their online stores?
In this video, I'll show you
how to prepare your training
data in BigQuery,
train a recommendation
system with BigQuery ML, use
the predicted recommendations
in production, and tips
and best practices.
Let's start with the data.
To recommend
something to someone,
you kind of need to know
what they like already.
So how do you know
what a user likes?
In general, there are two ways.
If your users directly give
you ratings of 4 and 1/2
stars out of 5 on a particular
product or piece of content,
then this is called
explicit feedback.
The second way is to
infer interest indirectly.
For example, maybe
the more time a user
spends viewing a product, the
more they're interested in it.
Since you're inferring interest
indirectly or implicitly,
this is called
implicit feedback.
As implicit feedback
tends to be more
common in retail
businesses, let's
build a recommendation
system using some sample
implicit feedback data
from a real online store.
The Google Merchandise Store
is an actual e-commerce store
where people can shop for
Google-branded shirts, hats,
and other products.
And a sample of the anonymized
Google Analytics data
is available as one of the
BigQuery public data sets.
Based on the store's
Google Analytics data,
I've cleaned the data so that we
can see each anonymized visitor
ID, what product
they were looking at,
and how long they spent
viewing the product, which
is in milliseconds here.
We need these three columns to
train a recommendation system
in BigQuery ML--
the user, the product,
and the ratings.
So the visitor in the
first row, for example,
viewed a particular item
for 59 milliseconds.
And in the second row,
a different visitor
looked at this item for 5,787
milliseconds, and so on.
So essentially, the more time
they spend viewing the product,
the higher the implicit rating.
With the data ready, to trade
the recommendation system,
we'll be using the matrix
factorization algorithm
in BigQuery ML.
So selecting the data
is straightforward here.
Select star from
the view or table.
With the training data, we
can now create the model
by specifying a model name
like retail recommender
in our data set BQML.
Then we specify the options.
Model type, which in this
case is matrix factorization
for recommendation systems, the
user column, the item column,
and the rating column.
I'm setting feedback
type to implicit
because the model is
trained differently
for explicit and
implicit feedback.
And then within AS, we
select the training data.
Now as you execute
this query, if you
get an error that says training
matrix factorization models is
not available for
on-demand usage,
it's because matrix
factorization can
be quite computationally
expensive,
so BigQuery it's
trying to protect you
from a potentially hefty bill.
To rectify this, you'll need
to use flat-rate pricing.
And to learn more about this,
follow the guide in the link
here.
After training is done,
you can evaluate your model
using select star
from ML dot evaluate.
But you might be
wondering what data
it's evaluating the model on.
When you create a model,
BigQuery ML automatically
splits the training data into
its own training and testing
data behind the scenes for you.
So this allows you to evaluate
your model immediately
after the model has
finished training.
Now of these evaluation
metrics, average rank,
also known as mean
percentile rank,
is perhaps the most widely
used metric for implicit matrix
factorization.
In general, the lower
the average rank,
the more closely the
predicted recommendations
match the behavior
in the test set,
with 0.5 being random chance and
0 being a perfect prediction.
If you're happy with
the evaluation metrics,
you can now make predictions.
To make predictions with
BigQuery ML on a single user
or a set of users to start,
you can run select star
from ML dot
recommend, specifying
the model you created,
and the user ID or IDs
that you want to
make predictions for.
To get the top N
recommendations,
you can order by the predicted
confidence descending
and limit N. You can also make
predictions on all the users
so you have the top
N recommendations
for every single user.
For example, here we're looking
at the top five recommendations
for all the users.
Note that because the output
for predicting the top N
recommendations for
every single user
can actually get quite large.
And because we may want to use
the results multiple times,
it may be better to store the
outputs in a separate table
that you can reference more
easily later, like here, prod
recommendations under
the BQML data set.
Now that we have our
predicted recommendations,
what can we do to use the
recommendations in production?
One way is to export
recommendations
for add retargeting campaigns
with Google Analytics.
First, by focusing on
specific products at a time,
you can create a new
column for likelihood
to purchase this
product based on
the predicted recommendations.
Then you can import
your predictions back
into Google Analytics
to create new campaigns
for those products.
Another way is by connecting
the predicted recommendations
with your CRM, like Salesforce.
And by doing so, you can
create targeted email campaigns
to provide relevant
products directly
to your customers' inboxes.
There are even integrations
between Google Analytics
and Salesforce that
you can leverage.
You can also export
the recommendations
to Cloud Storage, a
separate database,
or simply read from BigQuery
to use in a separate service
to serve the recommendations.
Now, at this point, I want
to cover some tips and best
practices, as you
might be thinking
how you can potentially
improve your recommendation
systems in production.
One question you might have
is, what happens to new users?
In other words, since matrix
factorization can only
make predictions on users who
belong to the training data,
how do you make
predictions on users who
you don't have any data for?
Well, this is actually
a common problem
called the cold-start problem.
There are many ways
to deal with this,
which is outside the
scope of this video.
But as a simple
suggestion the easiest way
would be to show users items
that are sorted by popularity
or what products
have been trending
for the past timed interval.
Another question you may ask
is, how do you recommend items
to new users if you know some
of their demographic data?
One way is to find
lookalikes to those new users
based on your pool
of existing users.
For example, given some
demographic data for User X,
first compare User X to
all of the existing users
that you already have
recommendations for.
Then find the five
most similar users,
we'll call these lookalikes,
to User X based on whatever
data you may have--
demographic data or otherwise.
Then make
recommendations to User X
based on what these
lookalikes would themselves
be recommended.
To find lookalikes,
one way is to use
cosine similarity between
User X and the other users.
Another way that you
can find lookalikes
is to find the nearest
cluster of users
and use them as your lookalikes.
And you can do this using
a clustering algorithm
like k-means, which is also
available with BigQuery ML.
For example, given
four clusters of users,
we may find that
User X is closest
in distance to the centroid
of these yellow squared data
points.
And so we can recommend
to User X products
that a user in this
cluster would themselves
be recommended.
Another question you may
have is that BigQuery ML does
batch predictions very
well, but your business
may need predictions on
a single user at a time,
and you need the
predictions to be fast.
In these situations,
you can export
your matrix factorization
models from BigQuery ML
and host it for real-time
predictions using
AI Platform on Google Cloud.
To learn more about how
to host these models
for real-time predictions,
you can follow this link.
So now you should know
how to build and deploy
a recommendation system
with BigQuery ML.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]